so recently Chinese developer a joy
released area f2 a blatant rainbow
succeed ripoff and when Ubisoft the
people who made Rainbow six siege asked
Apple and Google to take the game down
from their digital storefronts they both
basically said nah we're good so now you
be soft is suing both Apple Google and
the Chinese developer for copyright
infringement
[Music]
alright guys before we get into the
story the score esports has something
new for you cloten the show where we
discuss twitch drama and eSports news
well it's going live on Twitch
so now every Wednesday at 1:00 p.m.
Eastern you can jump over to twitch TV
slash the score eSports and watch me
Keith Colin and Dan break down the
latest news and maybe talk some [ __ ] so
follow the channel and hit that
notification button so you know when we
go live ok let's get back to the story
so back in November of 2019 EJ a
developer owned by the gigantic Chinese
tech company Alibaba created a YouTube
channel for its upcoming game area 52 it
was marketed as a close quarters battle
first-person shooter that would be
available to play on mobile devices the
problem is as you could probably tell
from the trailer is that it is so so
similar to Rainbow six siege in
everything but its name and when Ubisoft
found out about this clone naturally
they were pissed now because area F 2 is
being primarily marketed as a mobile
game Ubisoft went to both Apple and
Google and said hey this is clearly
copyright infringement it would be great
if you could take it down from your
stores and then according to Ubisoft
both Google and Apple said the
equivalent of nah we're good and
continued to feature the game on their
digital storefronts to add salt to the
wound after Ubisoft asked Google to
remove the game from its Google Play
Store Google straight up featured area F
2 on its home page talk about a digital
middle finger now at this point you've
Assaf responded with their version of
it's on mother [ __ ] and filed a
lawsuit against Apple Google and a joy
the Chinese developer and when I say
area f2 is Rainbow six siege with a
different name just check out these
examples do you like playing on Bank and
siege it's a pretty iconic map right
well here's Russian station from area F
2 for some reason is smoke your favorite
operator and siege well check out what
my dudes swap over here or maybe you
love kapkan all in his feelings with
this hoodie up
have you met his area f2 brother wolf
it's the same for a character select
screen z' weapon load of menus he'll you
board up doorways the exact same way as
you do in siege and ubisoft highlighted
all of this in the lawsuit noting that
quote virtually every aspect of AF 2 is
copied from r6 s from the operator
selection screen to the final scoring
screen and everything in between and
cool and this is not some small game
that's flying under the radar according
to Ubisoft since area F 2 was released
in March it's been downloaded more than
a million times in a lawsuit
Ubisoft alleges that one of the main
reasons Apple and Google didn't remove
the game from its stores when they asked
was because they were making a [ __ ] ton
of money from it
quote Google and Apple profit directly
from every game sold or in-app purchase
made on their platform in the form of
platform fees or service fees according
to public information ubisoft is
informed and believes and on that basis
alleges that approximately 30 percent of
the revenue generated from each game
sold on the Google Play Store or App
Store or each in-app purchase made on
the Google Play Store or App Store is
retained by Google or Apple as a service
fee end quote and here's the thing
because area F 2 is a free-to-play game
you have to pay to literally do anything
want new characters weapons or Maps get
ready to pay up and Ubisoft is alleging
that although Apple and Google might not
be making money off the sale of the game
since its free they are definitely
raking in cash of the in-game purchases
now you might be thinking well maybe
Apple and Google didn't know that area F
2 was a clone which Ubisoft actually
addresses in the lawsuit the lawsuit
discusses that in order to have a game
on one of these digital storefronts you
need to apply for and be granted a
developer account sign a standard
developer agreement and give Apple and
Google just basically a bunch of your
information on top of that the developer
needs to select which territories the
game will be distributed to so Ubisoft
is making the argument that at the very
least Apple and Google reviewed the game
before the
their stores and possibly were aware
that area f2 is a blatant clone of
Rainbow six siege throughout the lawsuit
ubisoft cites the Digital Millennium
Copyright Act or DMCA which is an
acronym you might recognize if you've
ever watched it don't at me where if we
talk about twitch and the lawsuit notes
that in marketing the game eg the
Chinese developer did nothing to
separate area F to from siege even
blatantly ignoring customer questions
about whether or not the games were the
same my favorite example that Ubisoft
highlights as potential copyright
infringement is the promotional material
which looks like a five-year-old German
and if you're wondering why you saw up
didn't sue ej directly and just leave
Apple and Google out of it well
apparently it's really difficult to sue
for copyright infringement in China so
you've a sock did the next best thing
alright UAB you throw down a little UAV
you pick up the phone it's just Rainbow
six now this is not the first time that
a popular game has been ripped off and
the developers have been sued for back
in August of 2009 Blizzard sued multiple
companies over glorious saga a PC and
mobile game whose quote content is
almost entirely copied from the Warcraft
games and related products end quote
another example is back in 2015 when
valve and Blizzard sue two different
developers for copyright infringement
over dota legends and heroes charged to
mobile games that closely resembled the
world and characters of dota and well we
aren't gonna jump down that rabbit hole
right now that case brought up the
question of whether or not valve or
Blizzard even owned the rights to dota
and that case was settled out of court
in 2018 now when it comes to money you
besought this asking for a hundred fifty
per example of copyright infringement
plus the standard paying of legal fees
and considering their allegedly a [ __ ]
ton of examples of copyright
infringement
Ubisoft could be looking at a pretty big
payout but there's also a bit of a good
news/bad news situation happening here
the good news is after you saw filed the
lawsuit eg removed area F 2 from both
storefronts and took it offline right
now you can't play it the bad news is if
your Ubisoft is that each I released a
statement saying that the game was taken
offline
to quote carry out improvement
in order to deliver a better experience
to players end quote
now the statement doesn't mention the
lawsuit so what does carry out
improvements actually mean well in an
interview with game Daily Dot vis lawyer
Richard Hogue says that quote in this
case there's no real reason to mention
the lawsuit because anyone that wants to
know about that already does because you
want to be careful not to admit to any
wrongdoing as you take this action that
looks like for all of the world like you
did something wrong so without fighting
those legalities here each eye basically
says you know what we wanted to make
some changes anyway
end quote yeah so basically expect to
see area f2 back in action sometime soon
just hopefully looking a lot less like
Rainbow six siege did you guys ever have
any favorite like blatant ripoff ripoffs
at popular games that you played as a
kid or even now the other one it's not a
ripoff
remember that Kanye West like Coca Cola
game that came out a while ago it was
did not make it up I'll find it don't
worry